with the post TI shuffle still in full
effect every single day we're seeing new
teams form and player traits happen and
that god is thinking about the most
impactful player swaps of the past keep
in mind we're not talking about team
formation but player changes so here are
our picks for the top 10 most impactful
roster changes in dota 2 history kicking
off our list is the move of yow DD DD C
and the legendary leader Zhao 8 - LGD
gaming the roster change added a
tremendous amount of veteran talent to
the squad and under the guidance of
director 8 LGD experienced more than a
full year as one of the best teams in
the world the most important things are
note about this team is how extremely
disciplined they are and how well they
mess together no matter what tournament
they attended LGD were a threat to take
it all and it all started with this move
when you have just two days to find four
new players and end up creating a TI
runner up you know you've done a good
job which is why digital Chaos's
emergency roster rebuilt from March of
2016
comes in at number 9 while the team
looked unusual on paper we misery Saxa
mu and resolution would prove the
doubters wrong with their performance at
TI 6
[Music]
guess what the lad
afterwards the roster posted a mixed bag
of results but you can't deny their
influence on the NA DOTA landscape and
the level of performance their presence
in the region demanded of other teams
the revamp of newbie in late 2016 takes
number 8 on our list for revitalizing
the former TI winner with some serious
talent the addition of SCCC wu9 and
faith to the team added skill and smarts
exactly what newbie needed to become a
contender again after a few dismal years
you can see the upward trajectory of the
team after the move as Newby went from
disappointment to one of the best teams
in China
beautiful the genie comes out CCC with
the buzzer both the stutter to next
top contenders at any events they
attended this newbie is still one to
fear to this day coming in at number
seven is the move of artisans I to team
secret forming quite possibly the most
skilled roster in dota2 history you can
name a team that has more fun with the
game than secret seems to have it so
confident in their own abilities and
each other's abilities that they can
just you know sort of pick whatever they
want to and have fun with it leaving
aside their flop at ti5 there are teases
I era of secret were one of the most
dominant teams in 2015 during a time of
some truly scary competition
secret were good before but this move
made them great no matter how briefly OG
was already a two-time major winning
team so any roster changes were going to
be met with massive expectation
thankfully jer axe s4 and anna joining
the roster proved to be just what the
doctor ordered and the big word that
holding him there but the damage you'll
drop the hammer for the bash again it's
still doing its work their tail this
timbersaw needs a man during the damage
until anna
throws a lockdown you actually have the
fight going the way of RG two more major
titles later and top four finishes at
six premier events it's safe to say the
roster change had the desired impact GH
his arrival on teamliquid takes number
five on this list while miracle joining
the team was a big step
liquid truly broke through once gh
stepped in his versatility and skill put
liquid over the top in one of the most
competitive landscapes in dota 2 history
ready to freefall and his impact on
liquids winning run at TI seven cannot
be understated liquid was good before
but gh made them champions how does it
feel you are a TI champion you are one
of the best five players to play dota 2
at this moment
something the feeling is surreal I just
couldn't accept that that's okay it's
incredibly rare that a rookie player
helps the team win tournaments in his
first year of play let alone DAC and the
international but some male did just
that after he joined Evil Geniuses in
2015
that's real trouble right now for Ghana
mr. Suns gonna miss he could turn around
try new cut some of us ought to be paid
but adding a Li mm at the same time into
the mix EDG another incredibly solid
support to add to the lethal carry
potential of sumail setting EG up for
success and the results after the
arrival of the do speak for themselves
one of the most important roster changes
in dota twos history comes in at number
three that's right it's the creation of
the team DK super team never before in
history had the East assembled such a
team of superstars with mushi ice ice
ice Lenin and mmy joining the legendary
Kari burning to create one heck of a
stacked roster the team was a terror in
the early half of 2014
GJ DK are your starladder season nine
champions vegas 185 thousand dollars and
didn't drop a game they look real happy
they are the team to beat if there were
any doubt that they were top in the
world i don't think that there is any
time now DK is the strongest team and
while they would eventually fail to win
a TI title for a time team DK changed
the face of Chinese dota D GM's move to
no tidehunter in January of 2013 comes
in at number two once the Swedish
support joined his countrymen on the
team leader called Alliance they
immediately went from good to great
leading them to the top of the dota 2
world these guys are happy ice
apparently egm has a special victory
dance I'd love to see you can get that
on screen bit as far as that game when
Alliance just looking absolutely
dominant the scary thing about alliances
that their play is so good like it's
near perfection and their drafts are
also very like B I've never seen them
get drafted this entire tournament in
the months that followed alliance not
only became one of the best teams of the
year with the eventual winners of ti3
available death of a half HP a Cornish
breed Alliance surrounding from all
sides can be they want around there is
he
your international strand champion and
our pick for the most impactful roster
change in dota 2 history is the addition
of funnik and keroppi to na'vi in early
2013 while na'vi was already an elite
team at the time the change would lead
them to become one of the best teams in
the whole world especially in the later
half of the year window na'vi are your
starladder season 8 champions they take
home yet another prize 1st place at the
biggest ever starladder heroic MVP for
that game for the tournament for me they
may have started out slow but by the
time the roster disbanded after ti4 they
had won 10 premier tournaments and
finished second at ti3 making them one
of the most successful rosters of all
time and those were our picks for the
top 10 most impactful roster changes in
dota 2 history are there any that you
think are more memorable let us know in
the comment section below thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button